britain has a new king
charles iii will now lead the world's
most famous monarchy
and arguably its most successful
queen elizabeth ii transformed britain's
royal family
and earned a firm place in the nation's
heart
the new king has an extraordinarily
large pair of shoes to fill it will be a
very very difficult job
but we will survive
it's all in the breeding you know
the world is already looking at charles
the longest serving heir apparent in
british history
and the oldest british king to assume
the throne
how will he lead a successful modern
monarchy charles has to do two things he
has to keep his family together
and he has to keep the dignity of the
monarchy burnished
[Music]
we've seen charles enough as heir
apparent to know that he is going to do
some things differently when he becomes
king
[Music]
the greatest book written on the
monarchy still the greatest book written
on the monarchy is a book written by a
former editor of the economist called
walter badgett and the book was called
the english constitution it came out in
a fortnightly magazine in 1865 and the
essential point that badger makes in
that is that britain is divided between
two sets of institutions
the efficient institutions which do the
work of government and dignified
institutions the most important of those
dignified institutions is the monarchy
generations of british monarchs have
studied badgett's writings his influence
has even made its way into netflix's hit
show the crown there are two elements of
the constitution
wrote walter badgett in
1867.
batchat still contains lessons for
charles today like the importance of
religion for the british monarch
[Music]
in 1956 a third of the british public
professed the belief that the queen had
been specially chosen by god
almost 70 years later being accepted as
a monarch in britain
isn't quite so easy
britain's population is wildly different
now to when charles's mother came to the
throne britain was a kind of a stodgier
place today five times more cabbage when
elizabeth came to the throne than it
does now it's much more international
it's much less white than it used to be
and it's much less religious so charles
has to appeal to everyone in britain and
that is a very different britain to the
one that his mother took over
charles's coronation will be a civic
ceremony but also a religious one
as king he's now head of the church of
england the country's state church
as heir charles made a point of
supporting a range of different faiths
he visited places of worship like his
mother did and he did more openly
learning from other religious texts like
other sacred texts
the quran offers some profound
and perceptive understanding and now he
has a new title
charles is now defender of the faith and
monarch is the defender of the anglican
church now charles at one point
relatively radically said that he wanted
to be known as defender of faith
in other words defender of religious
belief in general as opposed to of
anglicanism the fact that charles even
considered describing himself as
defender of faith is a clear sign that
he intends to be an inclusive monarch
and one who is conscious of the great
variety of the nation over which he is
going to be ruling
charles may not go so far as becoming
britain's first official interfaith king
but he is likely to continue the strong
support he showed for other faiths as a
prince
[Music]
spiritual leadership isn't charles's
only new responsibility
he's taken over as head of a large
family
and with big families can come to vision
families fall out families disagree and
that's certainly true of our current
royal family but i think for all of the
personality clashes the queen was
respected by the various members of that
family and she tried to hold it together
i think the new king will find it
difficult to be as unifying a force as
his mother keeping the family together
will be very difficult particularly
because of his relationship with his
youngest son
falling out is one thing but wayward
royals have tested the public's patience
and risked bringing the idea of monarchy
itself into disrepute
elizabeth's popularity enabled her
family to weather repeated scandals with
little questioning of the concept of
royal rule even political critics
weren't immune to her charms
many i would say most australian
republicans are elizabethans as well
but charles isn't as popular as his
mother
a very good measure of just how popular
elizabeth was was the fact that we
basically have no republican movement in
this country i think charles will be
less successful than his mother in
rallying opinion it will be difficult
for charles to be able to do that
elizabeth could do it because she'd been
there for so long and because she did
her job with consummate skill charles is
a more controversial figure he's got
more pronounced opinions on things and
he has you know
had a difficult trainings his marriage
diana was a exceptionally controversial
one and i suppose in love
of course
whatever in love means
so it'll take time for him to earn the
right to get people to say that i may
not be a monarchist but i'm a supporter
of the new king
with charles as king
people may be less forgiving when the
next scandal hits
but charles has plans to save the
monarchy from itself
i'm pretty sure that the new king thinks
that he needs to slim down the monarchy
i think that he has been very
embarrassed about the behaviour of some
members of the family and indeed by his
own youthful behavior and i think also
he's quite conscious of the issue of
value for money that the public is
willing to tolerate
britain currently has seven senior
working royals funded by profits from
the crown estate to attend engagements
for the crown
in 2021 the royal family cost british
taxpayers 86.3 million pounds a slimmed
down royal family would mean a smaller
wage bill and leave less room for
scandal there are constant leaks from
clarence house that charles is going to
pursue a more slimmed down royal family
in sweden the royal family has been
drastically slimmed down pretty much
just to the air and the spare and there
are hints that this is exactly what
charles is going to do here
watching the bottom line might endear
charles to a nation of shopkeepers but
time will tell how thrifty a man who
allegedly has a valet iron his shoelaces
can really be
charles may have a household full of
help
but being king has its restrictions as
well
[Music]
the received wisdom is that the modern
monarch has to be inscrutable
charles has come very close to looking
like he's doing too much already
as prince of wales charles often spoke
his mind
famously passing judgment on subjects
from farming to architecture
raising more than a few eyebrows
what is proposed seems to me
like a monstrous carbuncle on the face
of a much
elegant friend
he's even been accused of meddling in
politics
most notoriously in the infamous black
spider memos a series of letters he
wrote to government ministers
in them he expressed views on political
policy that some interpreted as an
attempt to influence westminster
the monarch's job is to unite the
country queen elizabeth ii was careful
never to say anything controversial in
public or get caught expressing
political views in private it's a role
charles hasn't always played
fundamentally they've got to be like a
royal mum to the nation they can put
heart in the politicians when they come
to talk to them but they can't actually
tell you what to do because just as it
annoys you when your mother tells you
what to do it's not just annoying but
potentially for the royal family
disastrous
if charles were to take his right to
warn too far it could trigger a
constitutional crisis
it's a scenario that's captured the
public imagination even inspiring a
popular play and film
empowered by ancient decree i do use my
royal prerogative to dissolve the
parliament
this is a fictional scenario but it's
based on a grain of truth
charles's apparent eagerness to speak
his mind in public organic farming
delivers the highest quality
best tasting food produced without
artificial chemicals or genetic
modification
if despite a warning from the prime
minister given in the weekly audience
charles as king continued to voice
opinions publicly on matters of
political controversy then i would
expect the next step might be for the
prime minister to
write to the monarch reminding him of
his constitutional duties as sovereign
and in effect having given an oral
warning this would now be a written
warning and it would be a very serious
next step
it's happened before in 1912 herbert
henry asquith the prime minister was
forced to write a letter to george v
telling him to keep his opinions to
himself
on that occasion the monarch listened
so long as the monarch expresses any
concerns that they might have in private
to the prime minister that's not
crossing any political or constitutional
boundary it's only when the monarch
begins to express opinions publicly on
matters of political controversy that
might cause the government difficulty
that that behavior becomes unacceptable
but there are signs that charles is
ready to adapt to the demands of his new
role
i think he's less of a wild card now
than he was he is married to a woman he
loves he's been training for this job
for a very very long time and he has a
strong set of opinions in the background
but an enormous willingness to do the
right thing to keep this institution
thriving
in 2018 charles told a bbc documentary
that the idea of him continuing to
meddle was complete nonsense
there may be a new face on the throne
but familiarity will also be a hallmark
of charles's reign i think like all
these things there's a great need for
cool heads
king charles iii is the continuation of
a tradition an unbroken form of
government going back nearly 400 years
since the previous charles was on the
throne
under british law the monarch never dies
as one reign ends the next monarch's
reign instantly begins
as charles knows probably better than
most when it comes to the british
monarchy
continuity is as important as change
thanks for watching
if you want to read more of the
economist's royal coverage
click on the link